hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem
last stone way so this is an easy-ish
problem i would say
but we're also going to be solving the
second version of this problem last
stone weight 2
probably tomorrow or the next video that
i upload
so the context is that we're given a
collection of stones
each stone has a positive integer weight
so greater than zero weight
and each turn we can choose
the two heaviest stones and then smash
them together now what happens when we
take the two heaviest stones
and mash them together well in one case
if they are the exact same weight both
of the stones are going to be destroyed
if they are not the exact same weight
then
the smaller stone is going to be totally
destroyed
but the larger stone is going to
basically be
the difference between the weights so
for example let's say we had two stones
five
and four this is the weight of the
stones they're not equal so
when we smash them together the smaller
stone four is going to be destroyed
and the larger stone is going to be
basically
a five minus four that's what its
remaining weight is going to be so
you know we take the we start with two
stones and then we get reduced to a
single stone the smaller stone gets
destroyed
the larger stone is going to be five
minus four that's a one
so that's kind of what happens when we
smash two stones together
at the end there is going to be at most
one stone left and it could technically
even be
zero stones if there aren't any left so
what do we want to return we want to
return the weight of whatever stone
happens to be left
over if we don't have any stones left
over
then we can just return a 0 as the
default value
so i will say that this problem is
somewhat straightforward let's take a
look at one of the
examples and the reason this problem is
straightforward is
they gave us basically all the
instructions and the information that we
need and all we really have to do is
kind of
simulate these instructions we don't
actually have to find a clever way to
solve this problem we just have to
simulate what they told us that's pretty
much the best we can do
what did they tell us to do they told us
to always take the two
heaviest stones and then smash them
together how are we gonna
get suppose we had a bunch of stones
like this
how are we gonna get the two heaviest
stones
of course we could sort the array that's
one solution
but even if we did sort the array you'll
find that
it's a valid solution but you know when
we're taking the two heaviest
seven and one we're smashing them
together and then we're gonna basically
be introducing a new stone right so
eight minus seven is going to be the new
stone one and then we're gonna
to maintain the sorted property of this
list we're gonna have to insert this in
order which
might be a little bit annoying but i
think it is a valid solution but another
solution
is going to be using a heap not a min
heap in this case but we're actually
going to be using a max heap
because we're going to be taking the max
stones each iteration in order to take
this
input array and transform it into a max
heap is actually an
o of n time operation uh with the
heapify function
but every time that we want to actually
get the maximum from here
that's going to be a log n operation and
how many times potentially are we
actually going to need to get the
maximum
from here n times so n multiplied by log
n
that's what's going to be the overall
time complexity
of this solution now how is it actually
going to work
well basically as i mentioned we're
gonna simulate so
we're gonna assume we have a max heap
here we're gonna get the largest stone
it's gonna be an eight we're gonna get
the second largest stone it's gonna be
a seven we're gonna smash them together
we have eight
and seven smashing them together seven
is smaller so this is going to be
destroyed
eight is gonna be transformed into a one
now so we can let's just introduce
another one
to this list and we're gonna continue
the simulation right we're gonna get the
now two biggest stones it's gonna be a
four
and a two what's going to happen with
four and
two well two is smaller so that's gonna
be destroyed
four is going to basically be four minus
two which is gonna be two
so we can insert that into our max heap
so now we're gonna insert a two
now we are left with it's a little bit
messy but we're left with
a two a one and a couple ones
so when we smash these two together
we're actually gonna be left with a
single one i won't
draw that because i think at this point
you probably get the idea then we're
left with three ones
what's going to happen with these three
ones well two of them are going to be
smashed together
and then we're left with a single one
left and we have nothing left
we have no other stones to smash this
one with
so when everything is said and done we
will be remaining
with a single stone so we can go ahead
and return uh
one as the return value and you know it
could have been a little bit different
it could have been
something like okay we're left with two
ones then they get smashed together and
then we have
nothing left so then if we had nothing
left we could return a zero but that's
not the case in
in this example we do end up returning a
one as you can see
down here this problem is pretty
straightforward if you have a decent
understanding of
heaps and their time complexities in
this case the only tricky part for us in
the code
is going to be python does not actually
have max heaps
so we're going to have to use a min heap
to basically simulate a max heap and you
can do that
by basically you know assume we had some
kind of heap we would want eight to be
the maximum value and then suppose we
had some other values three and five
but this is how a mac a real max heap
would work
but if we are actually implementing this
with a min
heap it's going to be the opposite of
this but we still want 8 to be
the the value that we get from the root
so what we're going to do is actually
have negatives
we're basically gonna multiply every
value in the heap
by negative one so that the minimum
which is
eight negative eight in this case is
going to be popped when we want the
maximum and then when we pop this we're
gonna get negative eight but we can just
convert it we can get the absolute value
of this
and then just convert it back into an
eight that's kind of how
unfortunately we're gonna have to do
this in python in other languages i
think you can just get a regular max
heap
but i think that's all the information
we need now we can hop on into the code
but before i do let me just give you a
very quick word from our sponsor for
today
interviewing dot io if you want to get
hired
at top tech companies like google
facebook and
amazon then you need to check out
interviewing dot io
you'll practice realistic coding
interviews
with senior engineers who will give you
detailed feedback
on exactly what you need to work on they
have the
largest network of vetted and
experienced
tech interviewers in the world so you
can book an interview
with as little as 24 hours notice
and the best part you don't even have to
pay
until you get hired please check out the
link in the description below
for more details okay so now let's get
into the code like i said we're going to
be writing the simulation
for this problem and so the first thing
we want to do is put all of these stones
into a max heap
now python does not have max heap so
we're gonna put these in a min heap but
we're gonna multiply every one of these
values by negative one we're gonna make
them negative
so in python what i'm doing right now is
basically just going through every
single stone
and putting it into a list uh and
multiplying each zone by negative one
i'm putting the negative of that stone
in
this list and now i want to turn this
list into a
heap so what i'm going to do is heap q
dot heapify
this stones this is a linear time
operation
so now we're good to go now we can start
running the simulation
and remember we want to continue this
while the number of stones is greater
than one if we have one stone or if we
have zero stones
that's when we can stop the simulation
but until
then we are going to take the two
largest stones
how can we get them well we're gonna pop
from
the min heap we can do that like this
heap q dot heap
pop from the max heap not min heap
so pop from stones and we can that'll
give us the largest
and this will give us the second largest
uh stone
and remember if the stones are equal
that's basically we wouldn't have to do
anything right we just remove
these two stones from the heap and if
they are equal
weights then we don't really have to do
anything we're not going to add them
back to the heap we don't have to we
don't have to do anything
but in the other case if the second
stone that we popped was less than
the first stone that we popped and why
am i saying second stone well because
the second stone is going to have a
smaller weight than the first stone or
equal weight right because it because
we're popping the first one that one is
supposed to be the heaviest stone
but we you know we're doing it this way
but
remember we made all the weights
negative so
what we actually have to do is the
opposite of this case if second
is greater than first suppose we popped
you know this is kind of an example
suppose the first stone had a weight of
eight in that case it would have a value
of negative eight
and the second one had a weight of seven
uh
and the value would be negative seven in
that case then of course
negative seven is a greater value than
the first stone right
so that means basically this second is
the smaller stone and we have to destroy
second and how are we gonna do that well
basically we already popped it from the
heap so we don't actually have to
destroy it all we have to do is take
the difference between these two and
then add that back into the heap now how
are we going to take the difference
first of all a heap q dot heap push is
how we can actually
add to the heap so we're going to add to
stones whatever that value is how are we
going to get the value
well obviously the value in this case
would be a 1 right if we took it 8
subtracted 7 from it we'd be left with a
1. how can we do that computation
well basically you can just take second
subtracted by first
if that kind of confuses you if these
negatives and kind of that math confuses
you
you can convert these into absolute
values if you want so you know you can
take the first
and second and convert them into the
absolute value then the math will be
straightforward
i don't really want to waste you know
too much time writing that code out and
this kind of does make sense to me so
i'm just going to keep it
short and concise i'm just going to take
second subtracted by first
which will give us the which will give
us the weight that we want to add right
we want to add
a stone of weight one but remember in
our heap we are keeping track of
negative values
so i would have to i would have to
multiply this by negative one uh
the easier way to do this is just to
take first subtracted
by second which will give us the exact
same thing it'll give us the negative
that value that we're looking for it'll
take the difference between these and
that difference will be negative right
we'll have
first which is negative eight plus seven
which is going to be a negative one
which is you know what we want in this
case so i hope that makes sense it's a
little bit confusing
but basically this is our case and that
is the entire simulation code once we're
done with that
we can go ahead and return whatever the
value of the stone happens to be the
remaining stone so stone at index
zero but don't forget we actually do
have negative values right so when we
return
the value of that stone we want to
return the positive value so we're going
to take the absolute value
of this stone and also don't forget
one last edge case what if stones was
empty
right what if we didn't have any stone
left in here
well one way to handle that edge case is
just to take
before we return just say stones dot
append a
zero so in that case if there's already
a stone in
this list we'll we'll end up returning
that stone because it'll be at index
zero
if there's not a stone then we'll add
this
zero stone and then we'll end up
returning that zero
instead so this basically works out in
all cases which is what i'm getting at
so i hope
this was helpful as you can see this
solution does run and it is pretty
efficient sometimes it's more efficient
than other times so i hope that this was
helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
when we solve the second version of this
problem last stone weight 2 which is a
much more difficult problem to solve